Tom peles arrow joining us now my cohort
my counterpart my buddy from NFL Network
TP how you doin brother can't believe
I'm not seeing you on the back patio at
the Arizona Biltmore I can't I can't I
can't either have you already picked up
your goodie bag
I believe the window on that opens up at
noon and that's as far as we'll go into
the details all right good stuff my
friend
hey the agenda is always interesting
this year rules changes on the agenda
talk to me about something that you're
keeping an eye on well I certainly think
that the proposed onside kick
alternative is something that is
fascinating and speaking to people's EMS
otherwise so far the meetings everybody
wants a little bit more information on
this any votes are gonna come down
tomorrow it sounds like on the
substantive rule changes but think about
a system where you potentially rather
than trying for a nonsense if you're
trying for a fourth and 15 backed up
deep in your own territory to extend the
game it it sets up a fascinating
sequence of situations and scenarios in
which would teams actually attempt this
if you're down you know three scores you
score or you try it again you know what
if you take the lead against the Packers
you want to see Aaron Rodgers on the
field again and so you go fourth and 15
to then try to keep him out of the game
you know it's you always have done this
of course of the onside kick and in fact
you're closer to your own goal line with
this proposed alternative but you know
it's very interesting debate suddenly
you're gonna have old-school people who
are going to be flatly opposed to the
entire idea of it but there's player
safety stuff here they've adjusted the
kickoff rules eliminating the run-up to
the kickoff that of course makes it
harder to get onside kicks which we saw
in the numbers last year so that's a big
one then of course you know the various
permutations of the potential changes to
instant replay none of which would have
fixed what happened in the NFC title
game a year ago to the Saints but
potentially expanding some of the
reviewable plays and where you'd be able
to challenge well that to me is is the
main problem is if you are going to
alter instant replay and there are a
couple of proposals that
have been submitted a couple by
Washington that would make everything
reviewable I don't think in terms of
pace of play and time of the game that
that's gonna pass they want to add the
review of all personal fouls as well
that's a possibility but to me something
Tom that has been interesting in the AAF
and those games have aired on NFL
Network and I've been calling those for
the last few weeks is that there's a sky
judge who has the ability in the last
four minutes of a game to not only
change a call but to make a call
which would have alleviated the problem
that we saw in the NFC Championship game
and would have been able to correct a
call now in the whole seven week season
so far the sky judge has changed exactly
one call but if that call is of the
magnitude that we saw in the
championship game this past year why not
have a sky judge yet it seems like that
is not something that they're going to
be considering well I think first of all
Dan there's always been resistance among
the ownership and the competition
committee to substituting one person's
judgment for another in other words
having not just objective things that
was the ball out of bounds was his knee
down but once that pass interference
because when you read the rules on pass
interference if you have to have a
material restriction of the receiver
there's a very technical terms that come
down to an element of subjectivity so we
can look at the play in the antechamber
ship game and say that was obvious play
up and certainly it was it appeared to
be when you watched it particularly from
the endzone angle it looks like an
obvious call but what about the call
that's ten percent less obvious than
that what about the call is ten percent
less obvious than that every fan every
coach jersey players going to think the
calls that go against them are robots
that they blew all of them so this guy
judge should be intervening but kind of
where do you draw the line that's that's
part of the you know the gray area that
I think makes people a little bit
squeamish about making that huge of an
alteration the same reason they haven't
told over those calls in the past to
knock the sky judge on-site or whether
it's somebody in New York you have a
fake brother element that frankly at the
time where you're seeing the NFL or the
casino there's legalized gambling at a
variety of places off across the country
some of the norms are
in terms of that if you implement a
system where somebody who's out of sight
all of a sudden chains a critical coal
in the game or throw a flag that wasn't
thrown you know they talked so much
where after Goodell and others about the
integrity of the game people believing
that what they see on the field is real
well you know one way to call that into
question would be having somebody who
you don't even know exactly who they are
or what their criteria is making a call
from not on the field
well there's one word that comes to mind
it's egregious if it's an egregious
missed call or it's an egregious mistake
on a call then you have this person in
the final minutes of a game who could
overturn it but I do understand what
you're saying and I think that's the the
major concern with everybody in the
league it's the gray area it's right
what if what if it's egregious in one
person's eyes but it's not as egregious
in another person's eyes that very term
it is subjective right exactly the
egregious jumped over the Vikings Center
on Monday Night Football
that was sleepy that was leveraged it
should have been called that it wasn't
you know if you overturned that call you
throw a flag dude
maybe the Vikings get new possessions
for a touchdown you know cut into the
the Seahawks lead it's a completely
different game and I remember asking
people because I was right around their
December meetings you know asking
competition committee members about that
may said there's just there's no
appetite for having you know somebody
weighing in and throw in a flag that
wasn't throwing on the field let me ask
you about Gronk that's obviously been a
big topic of conversation for us here
today after he announces his retirement
and already people talking about the
potential of him coming back because of
his agent Drew Rosenhaus insinuating
that could be a possibility but you're
reporting that there haven't been any
actual conversations between the two
about a potential comeback already
that's what drew said when he came on
NFL Network a short time ago he's at
zero conversations with the Patriots
about that possibility but he said it
takes a feeling that he would not be
shocked if we see Gronk play at some
point this season I mean this is 29
years old but he hasn't played all 16
games it's like 2011 the oh he's missed
30-plus games he's had a variety of
injuries you know all the forearm
surgeries and the back
and everything that he was fighting
through last year I mean the guy needs a
brain so it would be natural to say okay
what if he comes back in October what if
he comes back in November isn't more
time to rest you know and then it was
healthy plays a shorter season it is
let's go for the stretch run all those
are possibilities you know every time
that we have one of these you know
retirement and then instant unretire
meant flashback talks all I think about
is cover and Brett farmer from 2007
forever way to oh nine to ten and rumors
you know there's one year Sam Bradford
gets hurt in the other room is not far
you know would he would he come back and
the Rams making a call that's like 2012
we did that forever
he is younger at this point the question
is just kind of like what shape is his
body in and does he want to do it you
know easy what more can you do what
Gronk has done I mean win another ring
you know okay but you got three of them
here it all grow you're going into the
Hall of Fame you get seventy plus
touchdowns you know at some point is he
just you know does he find his calling
and Hollywood or pinching stuff or you
know just being man about town I mean at
least now he's taking a step back here
rather than as Rose now said he could
have presented the Patriots for the plan
to say hey what if I show up mid-august
and Gronk didn't want to do that he
wanted to step away and so as now is
your time well and I feel like for a guy
who plays the game with such pure joy I
think the fun has been sucked out of it
to a certain extent for Gronk I think
the routine sometimes I've had guys tell
me as I'm sure you have to sometimes you
don't want to go to work on Wednesday
and bang heads with anybody when you've
been doing it your entire life you're
just ready to take that next step and
financially obviously Croxon in pretty
good shape our poll question of the day
though TP what would you like to see
Gronk do next I personally would like to
see him take up residency at a club in
Las Vegas be kind of a host /dj I think
he would really excel in that role some
people want to see him wrestle some
people want to see him go on the big
screen right away what does Tom Pella
Sarah want to see Rob Gronkowski do now
well be given if he wants to give his
body a break I wouldn't say wrestling
i'ma get you I don't worry slam agree
it's like the worst possible thing if
you got back problems and then I'm sure
you've talked before he's a unique
personality
yes he's nearly smart guy in terms of
football you can't play the Patriots if
you're not and all the different things
they asked him to do see me blocking
everything else you know but then seeing
that translate into Hollywood acting I
maybe I'm wrong I I find it to be a to
be a unique fit you know even being an
analyst or something like that I think
would be different I mean I certainly
think is a product pitchman he's always
been doing that that'd be a you know
pretty easy thing to do but I mean drunk
tours maybe get him I get him I know the
cruising license yeah yeah like a fifty
getting like a hundred foot yacht
something like that and he says it's not
just the ground crews it's cross he's
your captain he's showing you around I
could see him doing something like that
I mean he's got a pretty strong brand
and a pretty unique one too it could be
gras cruises Kronk flights he could have
his own personal little regional airline
it could be humble he could do a cruise
we've already had the grunt cruise like
he's kind of done all these different
things football isn't precluded him from
doing it I guess the only thing that's
left is seeing them on the big screen
and we'll see if it's a Howie Long
firestorm situation or not and he's only
29 years old all right a couple couple
more questions I know you're busy then
we'll let you go
is there something unlikely that you
expect to roll around a team that is
gonna make a move on draft day or prior
to something that might surprise the
rest of us or is there some rumors that
draft type rumors that are flying around
there in Arizona I think the most
interesting thing will just be to see
number one whether or not the teams of
two and three the 49ers and Jets can get
out of those pits and this is presuming
it's not a done deal at this point but
let's presume Tyler Murray goes number
one as much as we look at this
quarterback class and say well you know
the giant straight back and take Dwayne
Haskins let's be honest you look at all
the recent grass I believe I had that I
said this set on NFL Network last week
is all the stuff was going down with
Odell Beckham
I think there's been 11 quarterbacks
taken in the first round of the past
three drafts
and ten of them require the team to
crate up to get them so you've had all
these teams packaging pictures per
quarter I wouldn't be surprised at all
when it comes down to it as good of a
defensive drafted if the suits move
packaging picks to move up the question
is who does it because a lot of the team
side of Miami that you know has a
short-term solution obviously with Brian
Fitzpatrick we'll see whether or not
they're really want to take a
quarterback this year as opposed to in
2020 but who is that team that's going
to go up and get one everybody else has
a you look at it and says they got a you
know relatively settle quarterback
situation Washington would be one
certainly to launch because we just
don't know where things stand born with
Alex Smith running Case Keenum but
that's a one-year type of a deal you
know Cincinnati new coach and Zach
Taylor you know that he says that Andy
Dalton says quarterback right now but
could you see them make a move you know
even the Detroit Lions I mean there's a
lot of teams who you look at it on paper
and say it's not totally out of the
question the difference is there's just
not five teams sitting there you go ok
they're definitely take a quarterback in
the first
well obviously quarterback is what's
gonna drive our draft coverage Dwayne
Haskins to the Giants something that's
been talked about quite a bit I've
actually heard the Giants really like
Trulock from Missouri don't know if six
is too high to take lock and the
Redskins obviously need a quarterback as
well before we let you go there's always
something that's that's interesting that
you see you know whether it's in the
lobby or whether it's in the bar and
without getting anybody in trouble I'll
give you just two examples right when I
was there okay things that I things that
I saw one was Gavin Newsom formerly the
lieutenant governor now the current
governor of California tall handsome
dude walking around there were five
owners outside on a patio and everybody
was like who's that dude like what is he
doing and at the time he was talking to
the owners about a potential this is
before the Rams moved to LA okay so like
four years ago I remember that yeah yeah
yeah you might have been there I think
you were wearing the same shirt as my
careful oh that day because you guys
tend to do that every now and then
another one tom was it was kind of late
night talking to Jerry Jones there was a
shot of fireball sitting there and kind
of did a shot a fireball with Jerry
Jones that was
Nicole is is there anything that you've
seen that's compelling or interesting in
the lobby there at the Biltmore ask me
tomorrow you know that everybody talks
themselves away it's Monday that's when
that's what the party really wraps up
how smart are you knowing that I'm not
going to be here tomorrow to interview
you on national radio television Tom
peláez Sarah you are a good man thank
you for the time my friend baked it he's
one of the best in the business based in
Minneapolis the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience